Let's see if we can
learn thing or two
about carboxylic acids.
They have the general form of
the carbonyl group, just like
we've seen in aldehydes and
ketones, and they will be part
of a longer carbon chain.
But instead of having a hydrogen
here, as the case
with an aldehyde, or having
another carbon chain here,
with the case of a ketone,
we have an OH group.
And you're probably saying,
hey, why is
this called an acid?
It must be called an acid
because it is an acid, and
you'd be right.
And the reason why it is an
acid, and why it is more
acidic that just something
with an OH group, it's
actually a good bit more acidic
than alcohols, is
because once this thing loses
its hydrogen-- remember,
depending on what type of acid
you want to think about, acid
in the Lewis sense could be an
electron taker, and this
oxygen can take the electron
of this hydrogen.
Or if you think about the
Arrhenius definition of an
acid, it is a proton donor,
and this OH group
can donate a proton.
It takes away the electron of
this hydrogen, gives the way
the proton, either way.
But the reason why this is more
acidic than alcohol is
once it gives away this
proton, it is actually
resonance stabilized.
So let me show you
what that means.
To do that, let me actually show
you the bond between this
oxygen and this hydrogen.
The oxygen has this pink
electron, and the hydrogen has
that magenta electron
right there.
If you put this in a solution of
water, so you have some H2O
over here, this oxygen right
here really wants to take back
this magenta electron.
And as it takes back that
magenta electron, it would
essentially donate the hydrogen
proton to a water molecule.
So the water molecule would give
one of its electrons to
the hydrogen proton and
then become positive.
So once this happens, the next
step would look like this.
What was our carboxylic acid
will now turn into the
carboxylate ion, so it will now
look like this, so it has
our carbonyl group.
Now, this oxygen just took
an extra electron.
So if I want to draw it,
I have that one.
Actually, let me draw.
So this is the oxygen.
To start off with, the oxygen
had two lone pairs, so I want
to draw those two lone pairs
first. So to start off with,
it had those two lone pairs,
and now it had this pink
electron from the get go, and
now it took this magenta
electron, so now it has one
extra valence electron.
We can even draw them here.
We can count them: one, two,
three, four, five, six.
Six is just a neutral oxygen,
but now it gained another one.
It has seven.
It now has a negative charge,
and then the water has now
become a hydronium ion.
So you have the water here.
We've increased the proton
or the hydronium
concentration in the water.
This one water molecule is now
a hydronium molecule, so this
is now bonded with
this hydrogen
proton just like this.
This oxygen gave away an
electron to this proton, so
now it has a positive charge.
And this right here, this
carboxylate ion right over
here, the reason why this thing
was a stronger acid than
something that just had an OH
group is because the conjugate
base, the carboxylate ion, is
actually resonance stabilized.
It is more stable than the
conjugate base of an alcohol,
and let me show you that.
This thing can share its
negative charge.
Let me draw it.
It can take this magenta
electron, give it to this
carbon, then this carbon will
have an extra electron, so
then it can give back an
electron to this top oxygen.
So it is resonance stabilized
with this
structure right over here.
Let me draw the same so it
could look like this.
That's too big.
Let me scroll down
a little bit.
It could look like this.
And now, this took back this
blue electron, so now one of
the bonds is gone, and it
started off with two lone
pairs, so I want to draw that
there, and now it has
another lone pair.
It has this electron, this
electron, and now it has that
blue electron over there.
And now this oxygen, this top
oxygen, has a negative charge,
and now the carbon
has a double bond
with this side oxygen.
So now the carbon-- let me go
back to the yellow-- that's
the first bond with
that oxygen.
It had one, two lone pairs to
begin with, and now it has
this magenta bond.
So this pink electron
is at this end.
And now this purple electron is
at the other end, or this
magenta electron, and
now it has a double
bond with this oxygen.
And we know that when you have
resonance stabilization, it's
not like you're going
back and forth.
The reality is that you have a
half double bond between both
oxygens, that the electrons are
just flowing across the
whole place, and that stabilizes
the molecule.
And so to show that this is a
resonance structure, let me
put some brackets around it.
And, in general, if this R group
right here is actually
even better at withdrawing
electrons, so if you put
something that was really
electronegative here,
something that likes to hog
electrons, it would make the
carboxylate ion even
more stable.
It would make the carboxylic
acid even a better acid.
So if you put something
electronegative here, then you
could imagine that some of this
negative charge that we
drew in these two resonance
structures, can be sucked to
that R group, and then that
would make it even more
stable, and would make
the carboxylic
acid even more acidic.
Now, like in everything we've
looked at, there are some
common carboxylic acids that are
not systematically named,
that it's probably a
good idea to know.
And I'll start with one, just to
see the pattern that we've
seen in other things.
We've seen that this thing over
here, if we have this, we
call this acetaldehyde.
This was the very simple
aldehyde we studied.
we saw that if we have something
like this, which is
a ketone, we called
this acetone.
So you could imagine what we're
probably going to name--
let me do this in a different
color-- this
molecule right over here.
This is a carboxylic acid,
clearly, and it has just that
one methyl group, just like the
acetaldehyde, just like
the acetone, and so this
is acetic acid.
So the acetaldehyde, acetone,
and acetic acid for me are
fairly easy to memorize just
because they all have the
acet- part.
They all have that as their
prefix, and this part of the
molecule is identical
in every case.
And the difference is the
hydrogen, the methyl group
over here, or the OH group,
making this one a carboxylic
acid, an acetone,
and all that.
Now, a couple of other ones that
it wouldn't hurt for you
to know is this one
right over here.
This is, you could argue, even
simpler than acetic acid, and
this formic acid.
And then another one, and
actually, I recently did a
general chemistry video with
this, where we did a titration
example, but this is essentially
two carboxyl
groups attached to each other.
It looks like this, two carboxyl
groups attached to
each other and you
can see them.
This is one carboxyl group right
over here, and then you
have another carboxyl group
right over here.
And so this actually can
be deprotonated twice.
This hydrogen can be lost, and
that hydrogen can be lost, and
this is oxalic acid.
I'll leave you there.
And in the next video, we'll
learn how to systematically
name carboxylic acids.